chris is weatherson new jersey hey chris
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave hey rachel thanks for taking my
call i hope all is well by you
it is how can we help um
so i uh started listening to you for a
few months
and i got the everyday
app and i'm just starting to use it
i'm on baby step two and
i'm kind of doing this without
discussing it with my husband and i'm
trying to figure out
a way to bring up the discussion with
him
on this how long have you guys been
married chris
27 years how how how was money stuff
before you found
the show and every dollar and everything
for the past 26 years how's money been
we pretty much struggle um i
am the only one that makes a consistent
money
my husband has a company and most of the
profit and everything goes stays with
the company
so he doesn't bring any money home from
his company
he keeps it in the company for the most
part and then
when i need assistance um
he'll pitch in so his company doesn't
make a profit
for how long for how long 13 years
he's not made a profit for 13 years he
he makes a profit but very little like
5 000 a year profit
it's not a lot
why does he keep doing that
because he wants to what do you make
um i mean i make 54 but i probably
take home about 3 000 a month okay i
mean i i'm a little bit confused okay i
don't understand why either one of you
think it's okay
to make five thousand dollars a year
income and work full time to do it
in perpetuation
i mean he's paying all the bills for
business and
um paying all the bills for what
for his for the business he runs a
business and he makes five thousand
dollars profit
you said is that correct yeah
and that's all he's made every year for
13 years i mean if you did that for a
year
i wouldn't say everywhere i mean it
fluctuates
right but it's not a lot chris i mean
you're not saying like he's not bringing
home a hundred grand or something yeah
it's no no not at all yeah yeah it's low
so i mean he could get a job and make
20 times more couldn't he
she'd be willing to do that
i don't understand why someone would be
willing to work for five thousand
dollars a year
he's not making a dollar an hour nobody
yeah he's doing what he wants
on what i want to do and i make a dollar
an hour
i mean he's probably new it's probably
you know profited well you don't have to
backtrack chris i mean like
yeah i mean i think i think it's just i
think that the the point that
he's been doing this for so long not
making a profit and you guys are not on
the same page so
to kind of get to a little bit of the
heart of what you're talking about is
you guys have been on two separate
lanes for a long time when it comes to
money it doesn't sound like a very team
effort
um it's kind of more his thing my thing
and a lot of couples function like that
i put out
uh just a post on instagram last week
about having joint bank accounts and you
would have thought
i ran over someone's puppy like people
hated the fact that i mentioned having
joint checking accounts
so like it's not like it like you're
you're functioning in a semi normal
environment but what we say around here
is that normal's normal's broke like
normal is not good like we want to be
weird and so i think
the thing here with you guys is that
there's more of an air a marriage issue
than necessarily a money issue it's
the repercussions of the avoidance of
conflict and things within your marriage
are now
the money topic has risen to the top as
the kind of the filter of all that
coming out so i think
you guys working on the same team um
in marriage overall is going to be
really important and that's his wife i
mean i would
and again i don't haven't been in the
marriage for 26 years but i can tell you
like
laying it all out is very vulnerable for
you because all the responsibility has
been on you and a lot of women feel that
way they're kind of like the ceo of the
household is what we're the cfo of the
household a lot of women pay the bills
they do it all
um in her case she pays it all and your
money is paying for most of it right now
i'm paying for everything yeah i mean
correct you make you make 10 times more
than he makes
yeah she does right chris yes
yeah okay so you're carrying the
household by yourself and that's a very
lonely place chris
and so i mean do you feel that do you
just feel this do you just feel this
burden like you're exhausted
i i do but um
i mean this is this is our life that's
how it's been right
um you know well let me tell you this
after two decades of doing this we've
we've found that it's really really hard
to win
financially if you're not both on the
same team
and so getting it to that place like
ground zero there for you all is gonna
be really really important and i think
coming open and honestly
about what you're wanting to do how
you're feeling and it's gonna probably
have some tension it's gonna have some
conflict
uh but getting it out and communicating
it is going to be that first step and it
is going to be very vulnerable very
scary because you guys
obviously have not been functioning like
that um but man
the quicker that band-aid can get ripped
off and you guys start working together
and him know your what you're feeling
your values what your
what you're wanting your fears i mean
all of it all ties into that
to that money conversation chris if you
hear aggravation in my voice it's not
towards you it's towards him
um i'm just going to tell you what i
think because you called the show
okay i think you avoid conflict
at unbelievable costs
that the king of the world sitting over
there making five thousand dollars a
year has totally got you buffaloed
and you're afraid to say anything for
some reason or another
because he's a butthole or something
like that i don't know what's going on
but how a guy makes five thousand
dollars a year for 13 years
and convinces his wife that that's okay
is beyond me
that's just strange honey and
so i'm gonna bust up in his stuff right
here
on your behalf because you can't seem to
do it
so he's way out of line
he's way out of line he's not providing
for his family
and all in the name of he's happy you
know well of course he's happy
he makes no money and his wife takes
care of him he's got no problems
so you guys got some avoidance issues in
this relationship
that are off the charts and so i'm not
fussing at you darling i'm i'm
uncle dave's ticked at your husband
right now because he's not taking good
care of you
and you and it's got you in an emotional
environment where you're having to take
up for him on this show and that's just
not healthy there's just
this is a screwed up mess right here and
so i'm going to encourage you
desperately to get with a good pastor a
good marriage counselor
and the two of you start working through
this because everything you told me and
the way you described it was all
completely unhealthy
it's not good it's working for you
because you're not rocking
the boat but darling this boat needs to
be rocked
now you should maybe you don't like that
maybe you don't want to do it you don't
have to do it you're a grown adult you
can do whatever you want to do
but you called here and it's my
obligation when you call here to love
you enough to tell you the truth
instead of avoiding what is right in
front of me as i'm sitting here looking
at your life
that is just strange honey it's just
strange
and everything about the way you
answered the questions the way we talked
through this was
you don't want to avo you want to avoid
having to
confront him or bring up this subject in
any way
and there's a sense of fear there's a
sense of conflict avoidance in all of it
and i'm
i love you darling and i want you guys
to win you can choose to live this life
if you want to live it
but you called here and you get to
decide the life you want to live
your husband gets to decide the life he
wants to live
and um i think there's more going on
than just i'm having trouble getting him
on the budget with me
you're not going to get him on the
budget with you his other stuff's going
on here
this is the dave ramsey show